Speaker 1: When comedian and actor Bob Saget
died and there was not immediately a cause
of death announced, I told you guys there
are people who are going to say he died from
the vaccine, from the COVID vaccine.
There's no evidence of that.
There's no reason to think that that's what
happened, but people are going to say that
and of course, I was right and I'm not patting
myself on the back.
It was obvious that people were going to say
that because any time there's an unexplained
death now football player dies must have been
the COVID vaccine.
Bob Saget dies, must have been the COVID vaccine.
A prominent right winger, Candace Owens, is
now pushing exactly that conspiracy.
Now there is no evidence for it.
But she doesn't care.
Let's take a look at what she had to say.
Speaker 5: So am I a conspiracy theorist or
am I Nostradamus?
The answer is neither.
I'm just not on Big Pharma's payroll.
Speaker 1: Now, remember a lot of the people
claiming that their position on vaccines is
because they are not on Big Pharma's payroll
are the very same people promoting the Regeneron
monoclonal antibody treatment, which is dramatically
more profitable than the vaccines.
Just just remember that
Speaker 5: it's a pebble in their lives.
And so to that end, today I'm going to point
out another truth, and it will likely be deemed
a conspiracy theory until it's not.
There are too many healthy individuals like
Bob Saget, who we know have received their
vaccinations, who are dropping dead suddenly
and unexpectedly with no further explanation.
Speaker 1: Now you have to remember a number
of different things.
No further explanation.
No immediate, known cause of death.
Could it have been a stroke, heart attack,
et cetera?
At some point, if the information is released
by the family, we will know.
But understand that there is a fundamental
mathematical problem here.
The closer you get to full vaccination in
a country, the more likely it is that everybody
who dies will have been vaccinated in a 100
percent vaccinated country.
Everybody who dies of a heart attack will
have been vaccinated.
Whoa.
Did the vaccines cause heart attacks?
Because everybody who's dying from a heart
attack was vaccinated?
Everybody who dies from stroke will have been
vaccinated.
Wow.
You're telling me every stroke death was in
vaccinated people in the United States, now
we are in the low 60s vaccination.
That means anybody who dies from anything.
There is a two thirds chance that they were
vaccinated.
Causation correlation.
Candace Owens doesn't care, and this is very
irresponsible.
Speaker 5: Healthy athletes, young students
in their physical prime.
The majority of the males dropping suddenly
and unexpectedly in the middle of games from
heart issues.
What we know for a fact is that these people
are being mandated to take the vaccine, and
we know for a fact that these vaccines come
with a warning that they bring about myocarditis.
Speaker 1: Now remember, the risk of myocarditis
from COVID is higher, but they now have.
This is really a situation of when all you
have is a hammer.
Everything looks like a nail.
I remember when I was a kid, the Celtics player,
Reggie Lewis, died and he was, I mean, let's
say he was born in 65, died in 93.
So he was 28 years old and there were no COVID
vaccines at the time.
That is a death where if it happened today,
people like Candace Owens would be saying
it's got to be related to that vaccine.
And the truth is this happens and this happens
sadly more frequently than people want to
believe.
I mentioned on the bonus show on Monday that
my, my, my cousin, my second cousin, my mom's
cousin Fabian Berlinski, pretty well-known
Argentinean film director.
He died at age 47, was healthy as far as we
would normally say, a little bit overweight
when he from a heart attack, when he was in
Brazil.
And you can look that up on Wikipedia.
And it was it was tragic and devastating and
sad.
But these things do happen.
And again, when all you have is a hammer which
is wanting to criticize vaccination, every
death starts to look like a nail that you
can hammer in.
There were no COVID vaccines for a long time,
and these things happen sadly all the time.
There's almost eight billion people on the
planet.
As more and more people get vaccinated, more
and more of the people to whom everything
happens will be vaccinated.
Traffic accidents mostly will take the lives
of vaccinated people, et cetera, et cetera.
What Candace Owens is doing
is
extraordinarily dangerous.